climate change here is disrupting a way
of life that has allowed humans and
animals to live side-by-side for
centuries yes the were in wha is a key
leader within the African Wildlife
Foundation one of the premier
conservation groups on the continent she
tells me the droughts are frustrating
decades of efforts to protect endangered
species so I look around and I see a lot
of grassland and greenery and you're
telling me about the drought but it
seems like it's recovering pretty well
it's only inside the park just drive ten
kilometers out of the park and the story
is completely different and the reason
why you only see it in the pockets
because it's a protected area but
outside the community area it's it's
over graced this land degradation and
the springs have almost right up now
that leaves the elephant without any
water access and it has to keep
traveling keep traveling keep moving
looking for water just don't have they
don't have because the demand for not
for for the space is becoming higher
both for wildlife as well as for human
so every time wildlife gets out of the
park then you have the human elephant
conflict we have worried the incidences
of poaching and Portuguese becoming a
very very big issue because a lot of
people have lost their livestock to
drought and if they have lost their
livestock to drought then they don't
have any other source of income the
demand for ivory is now very high and
therefore that pushes them completely
into illegal activities such as poaching
so there is a direct relationship
between poaching and climate change
could we see a day in Africa when all
the elephants are gone my answer will be
a big yes Africa at the moment has
between 400,000 to 500,000 elephants
left but if we don't work extremely hard
then one day we are likely to find that
most of the thousands of you know
not even 100 years talk of 10 to 15
years to come come on yes we are talking
of about 30 to 35 thousand elephants a
year that's what we lose every year we
lose 30 to 35 thousand elephants a year
a year so if this situation continues
like that we are not going to have
elephants anymore in Africa and it's not
just the elephants
once upon a time and bacilli had more
than ten thousand rhinos today not a
single rhinos left what not a single
rhino is left in Amboseli National Park
they almost becoming extinct hippos
hippos the numbers are not looking very
good because hippos are so reliant on
water and if we have if we continue
having frequent droughts the hippos will
never survive they will die over
overheating
we're losing hippos already and losing
hippos already almost only species so
the large mammals the large wildlife
that we're so used to seeing yes they
will all be gone they will all be gone